foreign
-year-old daughter is in a relationship
she's now married to a convicted child
molester registered sex offender as
Christians what should be our role and
our attitudes toward him if I want
nothing to do with him I don't want him
in my house I don't think he's safe
[Music]
yo yo yo yo what up this is John with
the Dr John deloney's show
greatest mental health and marriage
imparting podcast has ever existed I'm
so glad that you're with us
or if you're watching us on the YouTubes
man it's the greatest one of those shows
also ever hey it means a big deal to
folks who are struggling pick up their
computers at night and are scrolling
through YouTube trying to get some help
with the marriages trying to figure out
what to do with their kids it makes a
big difference if you will just take a
second and hit the Subscribe button it
kicks it up into the algorithms and it
puts the show in front of more people so
that more people can get help if you
listen to it on podcasts leave a five
star review hit subscribe and it kicks
it up into people's feeds who may be
scrolling for
my marriage has fallen apart my husband
just cheated on me I don't know what to
do I'm I literally am so much debt I
can't breathe I don't know what to do
next
um my kid's going to school and I think
that the school administrators are nuts
and I don't know what to do
please just hit subscribe and it said no
cost way of helping out your neighbors
and so uh on behalf of all them really
really grateful for you and if you are
thinking about getting healthier in the
new year which everybody should be
remember there's no such thing as mental
health and physical health and spiritual
health and all is Health it all works
together it's all inner interwoven and
braided together if you're thinking
about making some commitments to get
healthier this year go to thorn.com
we've partnered together to give you all
incredible discounts on all their
supplements and go to thorn.com and get
all your supplements 25 off every single
thing and it will just automatically
deduct it from your bill when you log in
so go for it all right let's uh hey
before we go to the first call questions
for humans Christmas edition
by the time the show comes out they may
be all gone they are they are selling
like bananas uh but let's have some fun
real quick did bananas sell very well I
don't know if people buy bananas
I think so I mean you know is that a
good
um cakes Hot Cakes everybody loves
pancakes
not my digestive system all right here's
the question is it ever okay to re-gift
it's so great Kelly is like for sure yes
Joe for sure yes Jenna I would say yes
if it's like a white elephant gift
like if it's like a gag gift that you
got and you're like uh I need this for
another white elephant gift I would
re-gift it but you got when did you get
married a few years ago uh a year and a
half ago and a half ago you probably
have a bunch of cake plates you know
you're not wrong that would make for
great gifts later yeah I think I
actually have re-gifted one of our
wedding registry gifts to somebody else
you're not a good person already did you
know I think they only made nine cake
plates total on Earth and they're just
constantly re-gifted yes that's true
probably
Joe what do you think oh it's fair game
baby
once it's yours you can do whatever you
want to with it yeah now you have to you
know be reasonable about it
because if you play the game wrong it's
over
[Laughter]
that's the wisdom from the mighty j-oe
what do you think Kelly
well
yeah I mean I wouldn't re-give something
my husband gave me
but as long as the original gifter
is not aware as long as we lie about it
I'm all about the re-gift yeah here's
why
I I think the ultimate intent is not to
hey I want to give you this thing that
is going to weigh you down
um I think that gift is to give me joy
and sometimes the greatest joy I can
give get is giving somebody else
something and so maybe I'm just passing
it through although I did get some uh
tickets to a play one time to a
performance and I gave them to some
friends because I wasn't gonna go and
the person that gave me tickets was not
thrilled so I get that
um all right let's see
all right I got one more which Christmas
song would you pay 67 bucks to never
hear again the Christmas Shoes hands
down
you love that I hate that song you were
always singing that song and Jen and I
were talking about it yesterday she said
I know it always makes me cry I was like
it doesn't make me cry it makes me want
to gouge my eardrums out with this dull
spoon Jenna what about you
um I don't like the Paul McCartney um
The Wonderful Christmas Time song it is
so annoying like I skip it in a
heartbeat I can't listen to it you just
blasphemed
yeah my husband hates the um Wham last
Christmas what I make sure to play that
either the first or second song of the
Season like I play Christmas music
November 1st I'm getting him the shirt
and I make sure that
um I play it and I'm like you've been
whammed and he hates it you've been
whammed
I'm not gonna make a joke on that Joseph
what about you oh I'm gonna go out on
the limb anything by Mariah Carey I've
had enough no I have to know when to
she's so great she's so great I
uh sometimes I'm by myself just walking
through a store the radio whatever
in the song The Little Drummer Boy comes
on pahrumpa pum pum
and I think to myself
I think I want to set my face on fire
just to see if I can still feel pain
I if someone was like Hey listen quick
uh
snap judgment or snap decision
a couple of days worth of projectile
rocket diarrhea or just Drummer Boy on
repeat
hundred percent I'm heading I'm just
gonna I'm just heading to the bathroom
I'm just heading to the bathroom with a
phone charger I'm not coming out I'd
rather just go in there they listen to
Pahrump pump I think it's the worst song
I've ever written but that's just me all
right let's go to Eric in Wichita Kansas
what's up Eric
hey Dr John thank you so much for taking
my call you got it man hey thanks for
calling and uh
you got to hear how the sausage is made
man that's pretty good I did thanks for
all you do and my wife and I are huge
fans and we listened to you for a long
time and uh
bricks and paintings are talked about
frequently in our house so oh man that's
so great dude that's awesome man yeah so
what's up brother how can I help
okay so I'm gonna give you a little just
a quick snippet of a background and I'll
ask a question but uh there's a big
disagreement that what my wife and I
have and it stems from our 25 year old
daughter is in a relationship she's now
married to a convicted child molester's
registered sex offender
whoa so she is married
she is married now yes okay
and so the question is what should be
our role as Christians what should be
our role and our attitudes toward him
and I think and I've taken the the road
of I want nothing to do with him I don't
want him in my house I don't think he's
safe and my wife has a huge heart and
she wants to make everyone happy and she
thinks that we should forgive him and
allow him to be a part of our lives and
just be cautious
okay
um
questions
what what was the what was the offense
um Luke uh lewd misconduct of a 14 year
old girl
so he was 20. he hooked up with a 14
year old didn't have sex with her but
right okay and of course he says he's
innocent of course but he but he pled
guilty okay that I mean sometimes uh
sometimes that's the easiest way out and
sometimes people get bad legal advice
and so that doesn't automatically mean
that they're guilty but
um yes I've very met very few people on
the sex offender registry list that
aren't completely innocent bro I didn't
do anything
um and I've also had some folks in my
life
um a couple former students that ended
up on that list I think wholly unjustly
and so
um that's why the the that question is
important what happened
how old is he now
he's
27. okay did he go to jail
yes okay how long is he in jail
I think he was in jail for two years two
years okay and what is his
um what's his life look like now
that's that's the thing uh it's horrible
I mean it's
um
she met him okay I'll just give a little
more background now if you don't mind
but she met him five or six years ago
and brought him into our lives uh she
had had left our home and
um gone to college and had some
roommates and then
decided to move in with him and his
family
and that's not as a boyfriend but just
brought him around we accepted him I
never did like him to be honest with you
uh it's just creepy and he's a big
talker
um and figured out very quickly that he
can't tell the truth
and so I because my daughter liked him I
rolled my eyes and I just tried to play
nice and just put up with him
and then
um he and through the first couple years
he interacted with our extended families
through graduations birthday parties
holidays funerals he would show up and
and that's the part that's so hard for
me to take now
um and even
her my daughter my I have a couple of
boys too and and uh during that time
they had people here at our house all
the time this was the place where the
high school was hung out and so there
was girls here all the time when he was
here and we didn't know this at first
about is that that's a violation of his
parole huh
well that's what we're finding out
exactly so he had a parole officer for a
long time that did nothing and he just
could do whatever he wanted and now just
a couple I think it was last year he got
a new parole officer and really cracked
down on him and we're finding out what
all the things he can't do
and uh but he just and we didn't like I
said we didn't know it at the time and
when about four years ago
um they had a baby
and soon after the baby was born is
where I just did a Google search okay
and I found out okay and I confronted
them and
of course he didn't do it and all this
and that and
and I was just furious because I was
just thinking back of all the times that
we had put people we care about
in the same room as this absolutely yeah
person yeah yeah
and then right after the baby was born
then he took off and took him away from
us
and retaliation of us finding out in my
reaction
um and we didn't see I mean we'd see him
but whenever we wanted to see him we
couldn't and he just played this little
manipulative game with us and uh
took her to Vegas and
basically told her if you don't marry me
then
I will take your son and you'll never
see him again
so she married him and told us about two
months later and she still she will she
never refers to herself as his wife or
anything she doesn't
um so here's a couple here's a couple
things hold on here's a couple things
I ramble so no no no hey trust me if
you've listened to my show I rambled bad
so
good to meet another Rambling Man um
there's a couple of false dichotomies
going on here that we can just bust
right through them okay
you can call his parole officer and say
for the last two years four years five
years he's interacted with numerous
teenagers and children
because he deceived us
as a clear violation of his parole you
can report him
number two your daughter
can if she is trapped
um if she's being
yeah if she's being held against her
will relationally she can go get an
attorney and say my husband is a
um on the sex offender registry he has
continually violated his parole being
around young kids
he threatened me to steal my child and I
tearfully and fearfully
um got married to him because I don't
lose my kid now I'm clear-minded I'm
sober thought and thought and I need out
of this thing but I don't want to lose
my baby
right well she won't do that she won't
I'm telling you she won't lose her baby
is what I'm saying yeah right no we we
told her that and uh there's there's
more to the story so she's adopted we
got her two and a half years old
she's had a troubled troubled life yeah
but a good life we had her in counseling
we had her in therapy sure y'all did
what you could Because You Loved Her
yeah and she's bipolar and
um she's but she's made bad choices and
we've had
when we get her by herself and have
conversations it's the I know I know I
know I know we can talk sense to her but
the minute she goes back then yeah she
is just sucked back into it and she left
him one time yeah and uh but then three
days later went back all right so here's
um man I think I'm gonna make everybody
mad with my answer here
and I reserve the right to come back in
a couple episodes and change my mind
because this is one I'd seen to Think
Through
um okay
you're you're making two choices here
number one am I going to be in
relationship with this guy
and number two am I going to be in
relationship with my daughter and my
grandson
right those are two different two
different
um questions you're going to be
answering but you're gonna be answering
with the same decision
okay okay
so in many ways you're playing a long
game here for the heart and soul and
mind of your daughter and your grandkid
because this relationship doesn't last
it ends we all know this
right right and so we're playing a long
game here the second is
in this is hard I got a six-year-old
daughter okay I got 12 year old son oh
yeah
um
but I have to say I'm a part of a
society
that has rules and boundaries
and penalties
and when you
have paid your penance
I'm not holding up mine to the bargain
if you return to society as we all
agreed and I continue to
not allow a shred of redemption in your
life
that doesn't mean I'm going to put my
hand back in the bag and get bitten by
rattlesnake again
but it does mean that for me
I err on the side of redemption I also
could give two craps about the words
that come out of your mouth I Gotta See
actions
and so I'm less concerned that he went
to jail for X number of years for what
he did
he got out he paid his penalty
I'm way more concerned that he instantly
violated parole
because on top of being somebody who
hooked up with a 14 year old he is
somebody of no character
who and more importantly perhaps he has
no he he has no regard for the law
because
I mean just think about it you just get
out of jail
and they tell you if you go within 200
feet of somebody under the age of 18 you
violate your parole you go back and you
go longer
and he didn't care enough to leave the I
would have left that house running and
screaming
when when one of my little when my
girlfriend's little brother showed up
with some of his friends you know what I
mean
yeah he didn't care
no and he's there's just so many red
flags that
so here here's here's what I would do if
I was you okay and this is me just off
the top of my head here
I would invite him out to a very direct
conversation with just us two
and say here's the deal
you've lied to me since the day I met
you
you've not been a person of integrity
you're on the sex offender registry list
and you've got every story in the book
but fine
you're also married to my daughter
you're the father of my grandson
I'm willing to give you access to me in
return but in return for the privilege
of that access to my family
is Crystal Clear honesty from this
second forward
and
um you're gonna you're gonna have
breakfast with me once a week
you're gonna check in with me
and if you choose does that make sense
so here's what you're doing you're
leaning into that relationship but he's
got to bring it
and let them know if you choose to not
come to breakfast with me if you choose
to lie one time to me my wife my
daughter
you are choosing to opt out of our life
and I know you've broken the law up a
hundred times since you got out of jail
I will do everything I can to send you
back to jail
and get you out of my family's life
everything
but I'm also willing to open up my front
door to you
if you if you walk the walk walk the
walk
I and here's my thinking on that
I know the recidivism rates for people
who are racist sex offenders who don't
get help people who do get help uh oh it
just depends that's a whole other
conversation
um but who don't get help it's so high
he's going to do something stupid again
and hurt somebody but he's been let out
right
that's right he's out
um it might be that this 14 year old
looked 18 and he was what 20.
and he's a young squirrely looking 18
year old it looked like like a young
squirrely 18 year old and he happened to
be 20 like
I I understand whatever right I mean
whatever here we are
um I'm way more concerned at his
cavalierness his
your daughter's story that's there's his
brother's in jail now for doing the same
type of thing to a 10 year old
and his his dad has molested his sister
and never got caught and so and to the
point where he says to my wife don't
come around when my dad's around because
it's not safe
but it's the environment they choose to
live in
but uh so maybe that maybe the harder
conversation is between you and your
daughter
okay
um
I appreciate the idea though I think
because since I found out I've
he's scared to death at me so if I'm
around he leaves if like if he drops off
the ground
baby or whatever but uh I mean you
probably haven't made it super welcoming
right I wouldn't have no right
absolutely not yeah no I want him to be
uncomfortable there you go
um and so maybe the
man
yeah I think I think the relationship
with the daughter I think you hit she
wrote me a letter about a year ago okay
and I just pulled that letter out in the
last couple days and
she thanked me for everything said I
made bad choices but you still love me
and
um actually
I need to read that letter once a month
yeah you do you do you do because you
beat yourself up over the situation now
you're blaming yourself okay don't do
that oh yeah you guys worked your butts
off
okay you'll love that girl with
everything you had
yes and it might be a season
a harrowing nightmare season
where you call your daughter and you
take her to breakfast and you say
foreign 's not safe
I can't stand by and watch my grandkid
my baby girl
be in this situation and I also know the
limits of what I can do as an adult
you're a grown-up you can do what you're
going to do
right and so I am choosing
to opt out of our relationship for this
season because you've chosen him over us
and
good to you you leaved and cleaved
I just can't participate in this
and I'll always love you I will not
always love your decisions those aren't
mutually exclusive
no you're right but at some point I have
to for me and my family I gotta draw a
line this guy can't come to our house
you can't I can't no but I could could
we just allow her to come and bring
the kiddo
and just knowing that he's not welcome
or is that just I mean you can but
you're putting your daughter in a
position to choose between her husband
and her family
yeah and that's what she's done in the
last couple years yeah it's been four
years actually that's choosing to create
an environment where you know your
daughter can't win
that's true right she I mean that's what
it is it's what you're doing there is
you're making her the
she becomes the fulcrum of that leverage
you want what you want because you want
to see that kid and you want to hug your
daughter
but you do it at the expense of her
husband
and so she's got to choose to exit out
of her relationship moment children with
her husband to enter into a relationship
with Mom and Dad and then she's gotta
exit out of that one to get back in I
mean that's just just go run and be free
if you're choosing him go run and be
free but choosing him means you're
you're choosing to opt out of our
relationship and it breaks our heart
because we love you so deeply
this one's tough man thanks for letting
me think through this one out loud I do
think
um faced in a similar situation I would
take him out just man-to-man
and say here is how this is going to go
and your margin for error is zero
I better not see a spit on the sidewalk
I better not even get a whiff
of you being dishonest you will tell the
truth and you may not even know what
telling the truth looks like because
your debts is a scumbag and your
brothers are scumbags and you grew up in
the house of
evil and dysfunction
and molestation
in disgust
I'll model for you what it looks like
I'll give you a shot
but because you've lied so much
previously your your margin of error is
zero
but I'll be that man you didn't have
and then it's Checkmate brother your
move
and after that it's a hard conversation
with my daughter
let me know that um conversation with
him goes I'd love to know how that
breakfast or lunch turns out and it may
be good Eric for you to write down what
you want to say to him
that way it doesn't get emotional it
doesn't get fired up and when he tries
to protest you can just seem to read you
this letter let's start there
that's a heartbreaker my brother we'll
be we'll be thinking about you we'll be
right back
deloney here and I've got a word from
this episode sponsor betterhelp let's
all be honest life would be way easier
if it came with a user manual marriage
parenting work making friends especially
as adults but this is the truth my
friends there's no step-by-step guide
you have to take ownership of your life
and when it feels like too much or you
feel stuck or overwhelmed it's too easy
to get lost in the anxiety black hole
I've been there but you can learn to
navigate this beautiful chaos we call
life in a healthy way therapy gives you
the tools to do just that and that's why
I love better help better help is online
therapy that offers video phone even
live chat sessions with your therapist
there's no waiting rooms no traffic no
endlessly searching for the right
therapist that happens to not take your
insurance listen better help us
connected more than three million people
with licensed therapists and they can
match you with a therapist at under 48
hours so don't settle for feeling stuck
visit betterhelp.com com deloney today
to learn more and get 10 off your first
month that's betterhelp.com deloney
all right we're back let's go to Jenna
not in the booth but Jenna in Madison
Wisconsin what's up Jenna
hey I'm good how are you good what's up
hey I just wanted to say thank you for
all your Insight tools and validation
that you've offer on your show at
um invaluable so thank you for that
thank you so much what's up
um so my question is is how can in one
goal about family functions during the
holidays when things such as gift
exchange cannot be agreed upon to put
further emphasis on this we're on the DV
Dave Ramsey the baby step two and I had
suggested to do a creative white
elephant gifts with the low cost with
the kids to make a fun game with it
instead my thoughts were completely
surpassed with my sister-in-law and she
doesn't want to skip the tradition and
suggested to do the usual 50 gift
exchange in addition to the white
elephant
um this completely defeats my purpose of
my suggestions
I'm thinking about let's just do white
elephants like cool let's do that and
and so I want to teach my kids like
contentment and the quality of family
time and I realize she won't change but
how do I navigate through this well
maintaining my own dignity and my
financial Journey
uh you you don't Outsource your dignity
that's yours don't give that to her
yeah dignity is I'm doing the best thing
long term for me and my family to keep
us safe
and for those listening who don't know
Dave Ramsey plan I'm a part of a team
here at Ramsey Solutions I work with
Dave Ramsey who's helped millions and
millions of people get their lives back
and get out of debt
um and we may do a whole episode on the
mental health of debt it's just Madness
um and there's a series of baby steps
um and you're on baby step two which
means you are feverishly paying off
debts knocking out credit cards and
student loans and paying off car notes
and all that right correct yes and a
hard part of that is the holidays is
when you have to tell your kids and your
family hey we don't have a ton of money
for gifts this year we're trying to
change our lives and become safe
and you sounds like you announced that
plan to your family and your
sister-in-law was like
um I want my gifts
yeah basically she's she's kind of the
type that likes to keep up with the
Joneses
um you know brand name the new car that
um it was really difficult because in
the past two whatever gifts I've gotten
they've already have or have it in a
different color cool hey here's the deal
here's the deal here's the deal you know
it's hard it is but it's super not this
is a great moment for you unhook any
sort of
comparison with them uh you're running a
race anymore
you know what I mean like Let's Race I'm
not I'm not racing you
one of my greatest lessons I learned at
the MMA gym is I used to walk around all
the time like we got a problem bro I was
that guy what an idiot and then I got
worked over I got my head kicked in just
beat in by a male nurse named Mateo I'll
never forget him he was incredible great
guy two little kids he was about five
six we had about 155 pounds and he was a
boxer and he beat me stupid and I
remember thinking if I had been at any
little bar or restaurant I would have
been like hey we got a problem bro and I
woke up would have woke up three days
later in the ER right and what it did is
it humbled me
I quit walking around being like hitch I
don't care
like I just want to have a good life
right and so if if you am I in a
restaurant you want to fight me I'm J
here I'm gonna buy you a drink because
you're clearly having a bad day and I'm
gonna head on to the next place I'm out
and if you're like your kids hey have a
great day have a great day I'm just out
right I'm completely unhooked myself
from that and so this is a great
practice for you right now
you could tell your sister-in-law feel
free to buy all the gifts you want we're
not doing that
and if somebody wants to buy gifts for
your kids you can't absorb that shame as
though you're a failure as a mom because
you didn't buy those gifts too
yeah I think there's a lot of guilt with
it my sister regularly buys more gifts
for my kids than we do and I love it
my sister doesn't have any kids of her
own she is a great Gift Giver it's
incredible dude and I love it bring it
on
because I'm not competing does that make
sense
right I'm not competing I'm not in a
competition I love my sister I love my
kids and rock it on and if I were to
call and reach out and say hey nobody
buy gifts this year my family wouldn't
I'm so I don't have a bunch of yeah I'm
not your same situation but you've made
your boundary clear and here's your two
choices let me just get to that two
choices
we're not coming
and that's a viable Choice don't go
just don't go
or go and if somebody's gonna be a jerk
and hand out 50 gifts to everybody
that's great we didn't do gifts this
year just like we said we weren't
[Applause]
needed to have um ear surgery and so as
soon as I could get her in was on a
Friday and I happened to be the Friday
before of a weekend of my nephew's
birthday party and they live two and a
half hours away and so I had said like
you know we're not gonna be able to come
she's having surgery that Friday which
would work out great because then
hopefully she can go back to school on
Monday and she's like you need to change
that to Monday you're coming to his
birthday party I'm like no no I'm not
and
um and then the weekend came and she's
like hey um are you guys coming I'm like
no I said I was in a month ago you know
so it's like that that she doesn't
accept the no and we where's your
husband on this
so my my husband
um suggested to be passively cordial in
order to not create a rift with his
brother she's been doing this career
are very close and and she's just this
and everybody in the family just says oh
that's just who she is that's just who
she is okay okay hold on hold on hold on
that is okay cool that's just who she is
and now you have a choice
are you gonna let just who she is run
your life or are you gonna say well this
is just how I am
me and my kids don't go to these things
because here's the deal Jenna she
doesn't get a vote in your life quit
giving her a vote
right tell your husband
he needs to suck it up and talk to his
brother or he needs to be making the
phone calls to his brother hey we're not
coming to this thing
cool man
because if he had called his brother and
said hey one of my kids having surgery
We're not gonna make your kids birthday
party this two and a half hours away
um what a weird world we live in dude
I I can't I'm not gonna make it
um his brother would have said that's
cool man
right
I
I would have because I think his
brother's crazy going yeah so maybe you
tell your husband hey from this point
forward you're making the phone calls
I'm not doing this anymore
because I'm talking to somebody who is
not interested in listening to us
and if you're not interested in making
those calls to your brother when we have
to say hey we're trying to pay off debt
so this year Christmas is going to look
different for us
if you're not interested in making that
call great I'm not going
sure right
right this is the magic word boundaries
you get to choose them it is it is well
and
and
um
here's why you're frustrated yeah
because you've allowed this to go on
stop
you you you are now no longer frustrated
at her
you have an imaginary fantasy picture of
what you wanted this life to look like
and it doesn't look like that
and you're getting more and more
frustrated at you
because you're not setting boundaries
your husband's not stepping up to deal
with his brother and say hey man
everyone in the family is just rolling
over and letting this woman take over
every and stop
end the frustration choose guilt over
resentment every time
instead of just going along and spending
money you guys don't have and putting
yourselves in your family on even more
thin ice financially
which is going to cause you to resent
her resent Christmas resent the
Gathering resent everything
not giving you that I'm gonna choose
guilt hey we're not going to come we're
just not going to make it this year it's
cool
and if she chooses to throw a grown-up
temper tantrum that's how she chooses
that's her choice that's not I'm not
that's I'm not doing that I must not
doing that right so let her do her thing
let her do her thing unhook it
unhook yourself from her judgment the
Jones's judgment the neighbor's judgment
nobody gets a vote except for who you
allow
I'm just gonna quit being frustrated by
other people man they don't have that
kind of power in my life
you can have that too we'll be right
back
it seems like everybody's talking about
how crazy the housing market is right
now and how powerless home buyers feel
mix that with the stress of moving and
life change and job change and you've
got a tornado of anxiety fueling one of
the biggest purchases you'll ever make
this is not a good idea so if you're a
new home buyer right now my advice to
you is to focus on what you can control
like the people you choose to help you
in the home buying process you need
folks like my friends at Churchill
Mortgage Churchill is a Ramsay trusted
provider that's been helping people with
their home mortgages for decades and
their home buyer Edge program will help
you skip a bunch of the stress here's
how it works apply to become a Churchill
certified home buyer and cap your
interest rate for 90 days then you'll
get a five thousand dollar seller
guarantee to help your offer stand out
so go ahead take a deep breath because
Churchill has your back check them out
at churchillmortgage.com deloney and get
the home buyer Edge today this is a paid
advertisement nmls ID 1591 nmls
consumeraccess.org Equal Housing lender
1749 Mallory Lane Suite 100 Brentwood
Tennessee 37027 programs are for select
loan types only and not available in all
states or locations
all right we're back let's go to Katie
and in Dallas Texas what's up Katie
hi there what's up
oh just anxious don't be anxious this is
the anti-anxiety show
that's why I'm calling so what's up
what's up
oh my question is
how do I get over the fear slash anxiety
of my husband dying
so my husband's perfectly healthy like
there's nothing wrong with him so it
sounds ridiculous for me to ask that
don't start out judging yourself we
haven't even gotten going yet
100 chip a hundred percent chance
at some point your husband dies
right right
there's just a statement that's a fact
there's a period at the end of that
sentence it happens at some point
so you're not crazy
okay okay your alarm systems may be
going off they may be detecting things
whatever but you're not crazy okay your
body's just trying to take care of you
so tell me more
um my husband and I first started dating
we were about
22 and 24 and he told me hey I think I'm
gonna die at 25. I just have this
feeling I've had this feeling my whole
life
so until he turned 25 I was like
panicking and then of course he's fine
we're 30 and 31 now but at dinner the
other night I asked him I was like hey
what's your goals for life you know mine
was like to write a book and to maybe
have kids and so I was expecting
something like start a business or
something
and he told me he was like I'm gonna die
young
and I was like oh what and he was like
I'm gonna die young I think about 60.
and it just immediately set off like all
this anxiety like I'm gonna have to
be alone I'm not going to be safe my
kids are only going to have you know a
father till he's 60 that's so young and
like
just started feeling anxious about every
time around my husband I'm like is this
you know the last moment we're gonna be
together like just these outrageous like
thoughts coming in have you lost
somebody did your dad pass away
um no but
wow I don't know why that's triggering
an emotion um I don't have a good
relationship with my father okay
um he did adopt me okay and then my
biological father was completely absent
okay
so your body knows that story right
yeah
that the man that's signed up to take
care of you
leaves
yeah yeah
it knows that in the mitochondria it
knows that all the way down to the Core
right
I told you at the beginning this call
you're not crazy
okay
now your husband
his death projections are they're
avoiding strategies
for the hard terrifying work that every
person has to go through which is how do
I make a good life
and it's easier just to be like well I'm
gonna die anyway
to avoid the what if I did start a
business yeah but what if it fails
what if I did have three kids yeah one
of them got sick what if I wasn't a good
dad what if they just annoy me and they
spend all my money
I'll just do nothing
it's just it's an anxiety response it's
a depression response right
that makes 100 sense I never thought of
that but that makes attracts he is
um it happened to me the other night the
Astros were playing
and I caught myself after the sixth or
seventh time in the playoffs
um with my little son with my son was
watching it together and we're cheering
him on and somebody would get out or
they'd make an error
and I would say uh that's it I don't
like it that's it
next guy's gonna hit get a hit I didn't
know more know the next guy was gonna
get a hit you know what I was doing I
was subconsciously projecting I was
practicing the next guy in line hitting
a home run and the Astros losing
I was practicing it the great Amos
taversky is a psychologist uh he's just
one of the smartest men to ever live he
said being pessimistic is stupid because
if it comes through you've experienced
it twice once when you thought about it
once it actually happens what a dumb way
to live
you know what I mean and so your husband
is like well I'm gonna avoid failure I'm
gonna avoid the hard tasks of leaning in
what he's got clearly got some stuff
that happened to him when he was a kid
that made him think very short turn had
very short-term thinking right the
difference between abundance thinking
and a poverty mindset right all I have
to say is this
sometimes the question what are your
life goals is terrifying if somebody's
never seen that play out
that's a terrifying question it's big
some big failures so it makes sense
there you go like why he would feel that
way yeah dude I've tried man I got in
the ring I got knocked out I got
embarrassed I got hit so hard I peed my
pants I'm not getting back in there
right
yeah and then he's like almost hoping
the world takes him in four or five
years
because it just feels like it would be
better than just hurting all the time
and now he's been with you for several
years and you're great
so he doesn't want to just disappear
because you're awesome but 60 is fine
I'll start when I start getting old and
it takes longer to pee and that hurts
when I stand up right you know what I
mean yeah he's just doing the math
and the question what are your life
goals I remember the the first title I
wanted to like the book on your past
change your future I wanted to name it
how to change everything
and I was all excited about that title
and I told my wife and she goes I would
never read that book it's too much
I can't change everything and I was like
well you can just change it all and
she's like that's too much
because I got two little kids I can't
change that I'm married to you I can't
change that we live here like right so
all that to say is this
I would break these questions up into
smaller digestible chunks
where do you want to live
where do you want to live
let's just make like a plan where do you
want to live would you read a book with
me
and then I'll read the next one and you
read the next one I don't read books I
know let's just would you just do it for
me
we'll go on a wild romantic Rendezvous
after we finish every book how about
that right whatever the thing is
yeah
um
would you like how much sex do you want
to have this year this month this week
would you plan that with me
right so we're taking what this what are
your goals what's this life gonna look
like and we're just breaking up into
smaller chunks and here's what we're
doing now what are our goals we're
answering the question who do we want to
be
who do we want to be
what kind of non-anxious Life do we want
to build for ourselves and then what do
we got to do I think that's more what I
was looking for it was question it was
and the questions what are your life
goals instantly set off dude I'm not I
don't want to be here
answer your question
um and then here's an important thing as
his wife you get to say I don't accept
that
I reject that
you married me you don't get the cash
out at 60.
yeah
because that's just when it starts
getting weird and I get super wrinkly
you gotta write it we if I if you're
taking all my pretty years you got to
ride out my last 30. all right and
you'll still be beautiful in the last 32
by the way so
um
like he can run his mouth about dying in
30 years cool but in the meantime you
want to partner with him on creating a
life worth living with the time you got
left
yeah
I'll not do anything
yep that's your anxiety talking
yeah right that's the fighter fighter
freeze like what we can't fight this guy
I can't run from it so I'm just gonna
shove it all down
all right
I'm just gonna sit on it and if you sit
on it long enough
if you compress it all down another word
for compress you know if you push your
hands down it's too depress right
and your body just says this is this
let's just don't move this is safe no
one will see us we can ride this thing
out and then we're done
and
as for me Katie I'm not interested in
that kind of life
me either right so two two important
takeaways here the next time your body
takes off on you
don't start with I should have or I've
got to
just be curious what's my body trying to
tell me right now what's it scared of
what's my body trying to protect me from
oh another man says he's gonna leave me
and then you look at him and be like
I you don't get to
right the other two did you don't get to
or maybe maybe the next time it's you
catch him glancing some way and it makes
you feel small or he says he doesn't
want to have sex one night and you
suddenly feel your body just starts and
like is he what am I being curious what
what I'm assuming curious what is my
body trying to tell me oh I don't like I
just I took that as rejection
maybe it has nothing to do with right
you start start being curious about what
your body's trying to tell you your
body's a pretty good uh signal signal
Giver if we can listen to it
the second thing is
is
um be direct with them
you promised me
you told God and our family and all of
our friends
they you're in this with me
if you die when you're 60 you die and
you're 60 but until we get there you and
I want us to build a life worth living
what is that going to look like
where we want to live what do we want to
do how much sex we want to have do you
want to have kids we not want to have
kids like what do we want that to look
like
if you die when you're 60 we'll deal
with that when you're 60.
that's not an excuse to cash out for the
next 30 Years
and he may need to go talk to a
counselor
in fact I think it'd probably be wise
I wish you would I I've been trying have
you gone
yes
have you invited him to your session
uh
no give that a shot I have mentioned it
to him nope you've passively been like
well it's helping me maybe it would help
you that's not it you're right it's not
it say it would mean the world to me
if you came to my next counseling
session with me I ain't going to that
that's dumb it I like you could think
it's done all you want you get to do
that but I'm asking you as your wife for
me would you go
because I'm trying to learn some
different ways to love you better and it
would help if you were there
and that's that sister's taking a risk
right
right yeah
he's lucky to have you
and your biological dead didn't leave
because of you
and that man who adopted you I'm so glad
he saw you and you were young and said I
won't take her home
and whatever's got sideways in y'all's
relationship isn't on you
he's your dad
right
right
okay
it's a high honor in my day that I got
to meet you and talk to you
same to you I appreciate you taking the
time to talk with me I want you from
this call forward to start being nicer
to Katie because you're mean to Katie
quit being mean to Katie
you've had enough mean in your life it
would be nice is that fair
it is fair 100 all right being mean is
how am I gonna deal with this moment
right now
being kind is what might next week or
next month or next year look like and
what can I do now to get there
mean is short-term thinking
kind is tomorrow thinking
mean is I could beat you today at the
polls
kind thinking is man what kind of world
are our kids about to inherit 10 years
from now
mean is you're an idiot kind is
yeah I'm sorry here you go ahead of me
is Katie why did you do that again
you're just gonna make it met
kind is hey honey
let's build a life worth living
you promised me you would
you're in I'm in
I won't ask you what your goals are
anymore but I am going to ask how much
sex you want to have I'm asking where
you want to eat for dinner
I'm gonna ask you where do you want to
live we're going to figure those things
out
build a life worth living
we'll be right back
seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships I'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up where you can
share hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to John deloney.com to
take the next step towards Wellness
that's own your asked change your future
at John deloney.com
all right we are back wrap up today's
show thank you so much for joining us
get the questions for humans cards go to
John deloney.com get questions for
humans
save your holidays change your marriages
have a great New Years
in the today's song of the day it's one
of my favorite bands I should probably
get this tattooed above my lower back
no you've got so many lower back tattoos
Kelly
this is more of a shoulder tattoo kind
of band it's from the great turnstile
from their incredible album glow on the
song's called blackout and it goes like
this blackout in the middle of the night
nope I did that wrong black out in the
middle of the light and now I'm back
down with a feeling and I Collide you
know it won't be long until the end let
the spotlight shine on me again black
out in the middle of your life just like
a blackout in the middle of the night
you know it won't be long until the end
let the spotlight shine on me and if it
makes you feel alive well then I'm happy
I provide and when you see me on the
floor it's just a part of my show
oh yeah it's just a part of my show oh
what a great song go check it out we'll
see you soon love you guys
[Music]